an inguinal hernia is the abnormal
protrusion of abdominal contents
such as the intestine through an area of
weakness in the groin muscles
the protruding intestine resides in what
is known as a hernia sac
in some cases untreated hernias cause
complications
for example if part of the intestines
become stuck in the hernia opening
its blood supply may be cut off leading
to the death of intestinal tissue
this is called a strangulated hernia if
a surgeon feels you are at risk for this
complication
he or she will likely recommend elective
hernia repair
traditional open inguinal hernia repair
requires a relatively large
single incision newer laparoscopic
techniques
require only tiny keyhole incisions or
puncture wounds
which generally result in a shorter
recovery period
when you arrive at the hospital an
intravenous line will be started
and you may be given a sedative to help
you relax
laparoscopic inguinal hernia repairs are
done under general anesthesia
which will put you to sleep for the
duration of the operation
a breathing tube will be temporarily
inserted through your mouth
and into your throat to help you breathe
during the operation
a catheter may also be placed in your
bladder to drain your urine
these will be removed at the end of the
procedure an
uncomplicated laparoscopic inguinal
hernia repair
usually takes between 30 and 60 minutes
depending on your situation
and your surgeon's experience he or she
will choose one of two types of
laparoscopic approaches
extraperitoneal laparoscopic repair or
trans abdominal pre-peritoneal repair
to gain access to the hernia your
surgeon will use sharp
instruments called trocars to create
three small holes or ports
through your abdominal wall the location
of these ports will vary depending on
your surgeon's preference
and the type of procedure one of these
ports is usually
located at your navel or umbilicus
carbon dioxide gas will then be pumped
through the umbilical port
to puff up your abdomen so its contents
can be viewed more easily
next your surgeon will insert the
laparoscope
through the umbilical port images from
its camera
are projected onto a video monitor in
the operating room
your surgeon will then pass various
instruments through the other ports
these will be used to dissect away the
hernia sac
and to tack a piece of mesh over the
hernia opening
this will prevent the intestine from
slipping back through the opening
before removing the laparoscope your
surgeon will take one final look around
for areas of bleeding or other damage
a port valve is briefly left in place to
allow all the carbon dioxide to escape
from the abdomen
finally the keyhole incisions are closed
with sutures or staples
and covered with bandages after the
surgery
your breathing tube and catheter will be
removed and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring
you'll be given pain medication as
needed when you're able to drink liquids
your intravenous line will be removed
most patients can leave the hospital
three to five hours after the procedure